Fallen to Furia liquid selling off a
liege
electronic to Evil Geniuses I just
suffice it to say there have been some
truly unhinged roster rumors as of late
some things are set in stone some things
aren't either way this might just be the
biggest roster Shuffle in CS go history
let's talk about it
all right so before we dive into things
I wanted to let you all know that we
just released a video covering our
recent trip to Tokyo we got to
experience the Snapdragon mobile Masters
first hand and watch the teams battle it
out in this incredible tournament our
team had a ton of fun exploring the city
and being a part of this amazing event
huge thanks to our friends at Snapdragon
Elite Gaming for sending us to Tokyo be
sure to check out everything we got up
to in the link below alright so the
player break is upon us CS2 is right
around the corner apparently and rosters
are being subjected to some truly
fatherless Behavior like
it's [__] now again a lot of this is
unconfirmed we are treating leaks as
leaks and reports as reports and nothing
more there's a very good chance that in
the amount of time it takes to edit and
upload this video even more stuff will
come to light I do not have the inside
scoop
though even if I did I wouldn't tell you
first things first Fallen to Furia of
all the rumored changes I think I like
this one the best according to a report
by dust to Brazil firia are in talks to
secure the 32 year old Legend as a
replacement for safe apparently they're
dropping well drop regardless of whether
they pick up the professor leaving the
core of art Yuri in que serado intact I
like this change insofar as it refreshes
and bolsters Furia without tearing them
apart obviously there's been a lot of
talk about art needing to go which I
don't agree with and I think that taking
the igl responsibilities off of him is
probably a much better route plus you
put the biggest Brazilian name on what
is now the premier Brazilian roster and
it's just a win-win for everyone and
overall very good for the region next
liquid let's just
yeah so according to a report by dust to
Us North America's Premier
Counter-Strike roster Team Liquid were
considering a move in which they would
sell off a liege and turn eu-centric
picking up team Spirits Patsy and
Bulgarian rifler rainwaker both signings
have since been confirmed as well as
Elijah's departure from liquid suffice
it to say Elijah's eight-year tenure
with Team Liquid coming to an end is a
very big deal he carries the greatest
franchise Legacy of any North American
player he's been the face of that roster
since they were barely top 30 back in
2015. truly the end of an era what's an
even bigger deal is that given nitro's
recent decision to step down they'll be
entering a new non-na focused era which
is
a decision the assumption is that
they're building around yakindar which
he basically confirmed on Twitter and in
that respect I get it Yaki is insane and
absolutely worth seizing will he Thrive
as the igl
it's hard to say since his lurking and
mid-round calling is so world class but
what I will say is that I think he's
enough of a genius that he's earned the
right to give it a shot if it doesn't
work out he can always just go back to
being a god-tier secondary caller the
issue for me Isn't whether a liege
needed to be replaced or whether they
will Thrive strategically by going full
European but rather
business implications of all of this by
turning eurocentric Team Liquid are
giving up their spot in the Americas RMR
and potentially
every major for the foreseeable future
like this really isn't about team
chemistry
it's about sticker money let's be honest
the spot in the major that liquid could
secure through the America's RMR isn't
free per se
but it's pretty [__] close and with
that major spot comes a [__] ton of all
but guaranteed sticker Revenue by going
to Europe you're entering the EU RMR
which is wildly competitive and
potentially forfeiting a massive Revenue
stream maybe it's a good move maybe it's
a bad move I don't know either way
them's the stakes in all fairness they
did get out ahead of this and release a
video explaining their reasoning and if
you haven't watched Joka Steve's
monologue on the [__] abysmal state
of nacs and everything liquid did to
save it you should we tried our best I I
think that
more than any other team behind the
scenes we were working with ESL blast
team owners streamers anyone you could
think of to make n a a place that was
more sustainable in multiple ways and
ultimately collectively we failed so the
long time TL fans that are sitting there
saying TL what what the hell are you
doing
I would just ask that you trust us
there's also the question of fandom
it's no secret that we the neglected
long-suffering North American
Counter-Strike fan base
have become sort of overly reliant on
team liquid's continued existence within
the scene for them to abandon us
that's tough but by the same token
like who were they gonna pick up in
their defense all I ever see are swampy
takes about how nacs is a joke and the
liege washed and Nitro valerante player
and then they pick up [__] Patsy and
all of a sudden they're like traitors or
something it's not fair that liquid are
facing backlash for failing to
single-handedly prop up a region it's
just not will I still cheer for them of
course but I gotta admit it's sad
especially with an entirely new
Counter-Strike around the corner it was
really fun when liquid were North
America's team our team the one we all
rally behind now they're just
liquid but again I'll still cheer for
them the rumor was that a liege was
headed for none other than Evil Geniuses
thanks to yet another report by Dusty
U.S word got out that Johnny Jabs turned
down complexity in favor of EG who
according to one of blix's reports had
their sights set on a liege the report
also claimed that EG was looking to
secure Jax and electronic which that one
wasn't on my bingo card that's for sure
and then early Thursday morning it was
reported that all of EG's potential
moves had come undone and that they'd
actually be securing none of these
players in time to meet blasts June 22nd
roster lock or you know at all it seems
a [__] ton more likely that elec and
Perfecto will both end up on cloud nine
which was substantiated in an hltv
report early Friday morning and then
yesterday it was confirmed that the
liege would be joining complexity after
all Elise reportedly eyes move to
another nacs team after talks with eg
and sour
five seconds ago Elise joins complexity
no yeah we're making jokes yeah no it's
so funny that I had to rewrite the
script seven times in between Wednesday
and today are you laughing I know I'm
laughing so yeah a liege to complexity
Call it any copium because honestly
where else was he gonna go but I think
it's actually a good move this roster
has always had potential they just
needed a bit of a boost in Firepower I
just wish it wasn't coming at the
expense of fang having a fellow Toronto
man's in Tier 1 CS was the dream dude
he's a really good player and I hope he
finds a good home anyway enough with an
ACS because Rumor Has It Navi is going
International since making it clear that
they will not sign players who reside in
Russia Navi have understandably
struggled to secure talk to your talent
from the CIS despite it being basically
the deepest pool on the planet going
International opens up a sea of
opportunities and is in my opinion great
for the org long term in terms of who
they get
that's where things get spicy the rumor
is that they're honing in on little
Lithuanian rifler JL Emma the Romanian
homie who was straight up smurfing at
the Paris major and finished igl Alexi B
who just got cut from like he's third
team in a year or something which isn't
shade I think Alexi deserves a shot man
the guy's been tossed around for what
feels like four years and I just
honestly think he hasn't been given a
fair Shake there's smaller stuff like EG
looking to part ways with their coach
vorberg and reinstate Malik which is
cool uh not to mention a strawless doing
away with both their director of sports
and Hunden which is just one big fat
juicy
kicked up on the confirmed side of
things we also know that astralis are
parting ways with glaive which I mean
that's a big one I think going all in on
blame from an igl standpoint makes a ton
of sense and I've actually wanted the
straws to do that for quite a while and
nabbing both stare and borup is a huge
win in my opinion flame Z is also out of
OG and replacing Dupree on Vitality
which I mean look I'll be honest Dupree
has sort of struggled with consistency
and despite being the goat a actual
five-time major winner I think long term
this one sort of makes sense is that it
I think that's it I don't know look I
can say with certainty that for today
that's it alright if you're watching
this tomorrow on the weekend when we're
not working
you're [__] out of luck my friend we're
definitely seeing a huge shake-up
heading in CS2 and it really isn't clear
how it's all gonna pan out I'll be
honest I don't know how to recap any of
this all right like seriously I talked
with shocks about this on a muted live
yesterday and he agreed that this roster
shake-up
[__] lose right now there is a lot of
moves that I actually don't understand
honestly for someone
who's crazy
I can have since the beginning yeah like
there's a lot of
changes that I just don't get it I don't
get it everyone is just trying to get
the most young player with the best
statistic yeah so not taking care about
the team chemistry is not taking care
um about how this player is on a
personal level if it's gonna fit with
other players or whatever like they just
want a young age and big stats everyone
wants their best at their role but man
it's a team game and we don't even know
who is gonna be good on CS2 like the
future of Counter-Strike is right right
now
very chaotic I think that this CS go to
CS2 thing is gonna end up being a lot
more tumultuous of a transition than a
lot of us anticipated
but I gotta say I for one
I'm kind of excited to see how it pans
out
you have no idea bro this these updates
yesterday this I was literally oh my God
I was watching that video yesterday the
[__] a liege the skit his
announcement video was them reading all
of the announcements and I'm literally
watching this I'm like oh we're laughing
oh that's good oh thank you no no that's
fun that's cute